[Aplausos]
[Música]
tenemos que cambiar la forma en la que
estamos ayudando
sino voluntarios desde muy chiquitos
viéndonos de misiones apostolados
retiros
decidimos crear por nuestra propia
cuenta 30 millones que abrirá una
experiencia muy importante que
literalmente cambió nuestras vidas en
áfrica estuve trabajando en un orfanato
en donde había más de 30 niños y bien en
situaciones de mucha vulnerabilidad al
estudio allí se estuvo en un campo de
refugiados trabajando con la onu y
llegando decidimos crear algo en donde
pudiéramos enviar a más voluntarios a
muchas comunidades y poder abarcar y
ayudar a muchísima gente nuestro primer
proyecto seguir bajando en filipinas
estuvimos trabajando una comunidad en
donde toda la ciudad iba a depositar la
basura este lugar la gente literalmente
vivía en pilas y montañas de basura
hicimos proyectos de todo hicimos
comidas comunales en dónde se
alimentaron a más de 500 personas
hicimos unas brigadas de limpieza en
donde se recogieron kilos y kilos de
basura
inclusive mejoramos las instalaciones
pintamos murales y levantarlos paredes
lo mezclamos con nuestra pasión más
grande queda viajar pues tengo conocer
lo mejor de siete países en asia nos
fuimos con los elefantes en tailandia
nos fuimos a conocer los templos de
camboya y la cultura de la evidente
y bueno
en este viaje aprendimos muchísimas
cosas aprendimos pues la sencillez de
poder dar lo mejor de ti las sonrisas
que le puedes sacar a los niños nos la
pasamos increíble
volvemos a méxico
empezamos a organizar el siguiente grupo
de voluntarios para mandar entre 7 años
y ahora preparamos todo todo en orden y
después un año llegan los voluntarios
y nos topamos con la siguiente realidad
nos topamos que los bulbos que habíamos
pintado murales estaban en esta
situación nos topamos que las comidas
comunales que habíamos hecho en la
comunidad fundamental porque las cuatro
horas ya tenían hambre otra vez y no
había nadie que estuviera ahí para comer
a los niños
nos topamos que la brigada de limpieza
que habíamos hecho todo habían servido
de nada porque cuando volvimos al año
estaba igual o peor de como lo habíamos
dejado
nosotros sigamos con intenciones muy muy
muy buenas para allá
con el corazón abierto con y dispuestos
a ayudar en lo que fuera necesario
y eso nos hizo preguntarnos a nosotros
tener una intención es lo que cuenta
si una intención es necesaria para que
suceda una acción es necesaria para
tener un resultado y es necesario para
que sucedan los cambios sociales pero
tener una intención no es todo tener una
intención tener una buena intención no
significa tener buenos resultados y eso
nos pasó a nosotros nosotros sigamos con
el corazón muy abierto a ser un proyecto
social le ayudarán a que se pudieran
pero mostramos preparado si estamos
capacitados simplemente vamos a pararnos
allí para ver que éramos útiles
de hecho esto no es nada más de nosotros
actualmente millones y millones de
personas están saliendo al extranjero o
saliendo de sus respectivas ciudades a
hacer proyectos sociales o hacer
voluntariado entonces las comunidades
marginadas
pasar los estudios que se hizo a nivel
global se descubre que el 57 por ciento
de las personas que van a ser un
voluntariado en diferentes partes del
mundo de diferentes comunidades no están
preparados o no están capacitados para
hacer la labor que van a ir a hacer
y para dar un poquito mejor esto diga
que estamos hablando les vamos a
platicar de dos casos reales de las
fotos no son reales pero los casos son
de situaciones que pasaron aquí en
méxico con voluntarios muy bien
intencionados el primero es de una chava
extranjera que decide lanzarse en mexico
ayudar comunidades rurales a la
reconstrucción de vivienda ellos nunca
habían construido antes y no iba
acompañada de alguien que lo supiera
hacer simplemente se compraron
materiales y como pudieron fueron
levantando paredes los ninguno de les
empezaron a darse cuenta que la
construcción que estaban haciendo
inclusive estaba es tan peligrosa para
meter a alguien admira ahí pero para no
herir los sentimientos del voluntario
por las noches mientras los voluntarios
dormían los locales iban a reconstruir
el trabajo que ellas estaban haciendo
de esta manera desperdiciando tanto
dinero recursos tiempo y desempeñando
alguien de la comunidad que pudo haber
hecho el trabajo de la mejor manera el
segundo caso debemos voluntario igual
extranjero que se lanzó a comunidades
rurales en mexico hacer brigadas médicas
estudiante de medicina en los primeros
semestres con la mejor intención del
mundo
estando ahí piden hacer una cirugía que
él nunca ha practicado como novio de
otra dijo está bien me la bien saben
toda la cirugía y a las pocas semanas la
persona falleció
y bueno teniendo tantas cosas que pueden
salir mal en un voluntariado porque la
gente se está yendo a hacer un proyecto
social porque se están yendo de
voluntarios
basado en un estudio que se hizo a nivel
internacional
se descubrió que el 42 por ciento de las
personas que se van a hacer un proyecto
social a diferentes partes
y lo hacen por filantropía porque son
personas empáticas porque de verdad
quieren sacar adelante a comunidades
y por el otro lado de la moneda se
descubre el 58% de las personas que se
van a usar un proyecto social es por las
siguientes razones
[Música]
o porque está de moda porque los invito
a un amigo porque se ve muy padre los
voluntariado currículum porque todo el
año estuvo de flojo y no dice nada y
hasta dice cosas malas y quiero
remediarlo haciendo un proyecto social
o también por aspectos religiosos
encuentro el concepto bien realizado que
existe desde las épocas coloniales la
teoría del superhéroe quiero que se
pongan a pensar en su superior favorito
pongan
que tuvo que hacer ese superhéroe para
convertirse en superhéroe
y la respuesta en número uno va a ser
salvar a alguien
hoy en día tenemos superhéroes super de
la vida real y se trata de todas estas
personas que creemos que por tener
cierto nivel económico cierta educación
cierto poder adquisitivo tenemos el
derecho de ir a una comunidad vulnerable
a rescatar a gente para sacarla de su
situación pero que estamos creando se
está haciendo una relación vertical en
donde yo qué sé yo que tengo yo que soy
te voy a ti a rescatar de tu situación y
dónde estamos dejando la otra persona
otra persona se convierte en una víctima
estoy segura que la cuenta que están
viendo ahorita no es la primera que
vende este estilo este tipo de
fotografía se le conoce como la
pornografía de la pobreza
son fotografías que a lo mejor no con
mala intención pero estamos promoviendo
y estamos etiquetando en cierta clase
social oa ciertas razas a cierta idea
como los pobrecitos y como que si
nosotros o sin alguien que los ayude
ellos no van a salir adelante
y la práctica de hoy porque estamos aquí
dando este mensaje es porque necesitamos
cambiar la forma en la que estamos
ayudando
necesitamos quitaremos esta capa de
superhéroe y entender que no le vamos a
ir a salvar la vida a nadie y que esa
persona va a salir adelante este es
turno que la mejor manera de poder hacer
un servicio social un proyecto social es
con una actitud de humildad y entender
que no sabemos todo pero que hay gente
que se apoyarnos con esas personas que
lo pueden sacar adelante
y bueno les queremos dar una serie de
pasos son cinco pasos que a nosotros nos
ha funcionado bastante para hacer un
proyecto social y que hemos ido
moldeando a lo largo del tiempo que
tenemos trabajando en esto y muy
sencillo el primer paso es hagamos
introspección porque estamos tomando la
decisión de ser un proyecto social
porque nos queremos ir de voluntarios
es por las razones correctas es por las
razones incorrectas es porque llegamos
con mi currículum o es porque quiero a
alguien
busquemos adentro de nosotros que es el
motorcito que nos está moviendo para
tomar esta decisión
el segundo paso es identifiquemos
nuestras habilidades creo que también es
muy fácil estar para que somos buenos y
para que no somos buenos y para los que
somos buenos que alcance tenemos hay
gente que es buena para dar no sé los
números hay gente que es buena para los
deportes ok toma eso que estás en que
eres bueno moldeado y ahora si ven qué
alcance tiene hasta dónde llegan mis
habilidades en el fútbol atornilla mis
habilidades contables y hasta donde
llegue tu límite rodéate de gente que te
aporte es el límite que te falta
rodearte de ese equipo que sea necesario
para poder lograr ese impacto social que
quieren ahora
en su número 13 encontrar nuestra causa
y que queríamos usar entender con este
existen un montón de problemas sociales
elementos infinitos y si nos ponemos a
enumerar no vamos a salir de química
pero siempre va a haber un problema que
te mueve más que los demás hay gente que
lo mueve mucho la pobreza hay gente que
lo mueve mucho todo lo que es el
feminismo y equidad de género hay gente
que lo mueve el medio ambiente la
contaminación
un montón de problemas
explora identifica la causa que tiene el
corazón y enfócate porque si tratamos de
abarcar todos los problemas del mundo no
vamos a llegar a ningún lado
el cuarto paso conoce tu causa
siempre ponemos este ejemplo
hacer proyectos sociales no es como ser
un huevito en la mañana no es como ir
hacer unos tacos o una carne asada con
tus amigos hacer un proyecto social
me terca la cocina de las personas con
las que vas a colaborar
que nadie te platiqué quieres lo que
están sufriendo sino ellas qué es lo que
quieres aportar conocerlo con datos
duros estadísticamente te a investigar
fuerte entrevistas etcétera etcétera
y rodéate de personas que sean y que te
aporten al proyecto sus arte tú quieres
entrar no dejes que la incertidumbre se
meta en tu causa
no dejes no dejes espacio para que entre
la desinformación que entre la
el que salga mal un proyecto por falta
de información
y el quinto y yo creo que es el paso que
resume todo es actuar sobre nuestras
causas todos tenemos una responsabilidad
social bien grande y hay que hacer algo
al respecto pero hay que hacerlo de
manera inteligente pensemos en cómo
estamos hablando actualmente
y algo bien importante aquí es
aunque nuestro concepto de lo que es
ayudar se nos ha ocultado la manera
equivocada
a todos nos han enseñado que ayudar
significa quitarme la chamarra y de
hacer que tiene frío pues enseñado que
ayudar significa hacer tortas y
regalarles el día de navidad entre un
montón de ejemplos
pero si nos vamos al trasfondo de esas
acciones que estamos haciendo estamos
colaborando los círculos de pobreza en
donde se crean dependencias en donde una
persona se acostumbra a que una comida
llega por unas manos que se la dieron
en vez de impulsar el trabajo y en vez
de convertirnos en la herramienta en
equipo para que estas personas sean
autosostenibles estamos creyendo
dependencias de unos a los otros y
podemos estar generando más más que bien
siempre nos han dicho no desde el
pescado enseño pescado y eso se trata
hacer proyectos inteligentes
ahora hay una excepción para esa frase
y quiero que se pongan a pensar
imagínense a alguien que estaba huyendo
de la guerra que tiene tres días de no
comer está escapando
qué pasa si la persona no tiene la
fuerza para agarrar la caña de pescar
eso es las opciones asistenciales esta
es la excepción a vivir a regalar cosas
porque porque el que tú le des ese
sándwich o no si va a ser la diferencia
entonces siempre que vayamos a colaborar
en un proyecto social tenemos que
evaluar en qué punto estamos entrando en
qué situación está la persona para ver
la mejor manera en la que tú vas a
cortar
para terminar queremos terminar diciendo
que estamos muy contentos por el hecho
de que cada vez es más gente la que se
suma de proyectos sociales cada vez
somos más los voluntarios cada vez somos
más los interesados en hacer un cambio
social en hacer un cambio climático
y hacer enfoque en que ser voluntariado
no está mal ni bien la responsabilidad
de los resultados no caiga en el
voluntariado sino que en el voluntario
muchas gracias
muchísimas